おっしゃ
うあぁ！！
ハッ！ハッ！
俺は何度も言っているが
今年はお菓子・ジュースが食べれない
なので！
お祭りに行っても、屋台に行っても、かき氷が食べれないんです！
つんだ
マジで。マジでつんだ。
最近祭りに行ったんですけども
ほとんど屋台が終わってて
残っていた屋台が３つ！
ぼくはその祭りで何も食べることもなく、そのまま家に帰ったとさ。
さようなら
というわけで今日は！
すごいいい「かき氷機」を買ったので
今回は
シロップはね、もうね、ジュースなんですよ。僕の中で
シロップ以外の物でいかにかき氷をね、おいしく食べれるかを、
今日ちょっといろいろね、買ってきたので
果たして、シロップ以外でどうすれば
かき氷をおいしく食べれるかを今日は検証していきたいと思います！
では行こう！！
ポケモンＧＯやりてぇ・・・
ホントにオレは純粋に
かき氷をちゃんと食べたいと思ってるから・・・
ちょっといろいろ試してみましょう
これで氷をブチ込めば多分いけるはず・・・
なんで冷蔵庫壊れてんの～・・・
氷しか入ってなかったんで良かったんですけど、
もう全部ドロドロでした・・・
夏っぽくなって来たね！
おっしゃ～
じゃ、かき氷作っていきます
ひとまず
うん！
はい、というわけで、
僕は、ここでシロップをかけると食べれないので、
何をかけるかという話で・・・
まずはこちら！
まずはね、手始めにお茶をかけようと思います
もう甘さを捨てて、
もうお茶の風味を感じよう
みたいな作戦でちょっといってみようと思います
はぁ・・・　すげぇ！
伝わりますかね？
完全ににお・・・
いただきます！
ふわふわしてるかき氷
いただきやす！
うぅ～ん・・・
うぉいしい
次はこちら！
そうめんのめんつゆです
これはね、オレね、ワンチャンいけると思ってんだよね
これももう、発想の転換といいますか・・・
もうかき氷を・・・
かき氷を甘いものとして見ず、
もう、めんつゆによって、もう料理として！
食べ物として見るという作戦です
ＯＫ！
あぁ～アリアリアリ
アリアリアリアリ
風味がかなりよい。
これは悪くないっすよ
じゃ、めんつゆかき氷、
いただきます
おぉ～
あ゛ぁっ・・・
次はこちら！
ビールです
これね、美味しいって話を聞きました
乾杯
うぁ～っ
２３歳になってからさ、
ビールが美味しく感じるんだよ
お疲れ様！
よしよしよし！
うわぁっ
ふふっ・・・
いただきやす！
ビールだけの方が・・・
美味しいっ！！
次はこちら！
ケチャップです
ケチャップもまた、どう出るかわかんねぇとこだね
ＯＫ！
ケチャッぱっぱ・・・
プッ
ケチャップかけ（てみ）ましょう
アァ↑
なんかありそう！
こんな感じです
これは何かね、割とね、いける気がします
うん・・・
いただきます！
う゛ぉぇっ
なんなんすかね
なんか違う！
やっぱケチャップはね、
氷だとね、またケチャップの方が強すぎて、
こう、何か・・・
かき氷本来の力が完全に封じられた感？
次はこちら！
牛乳です
あっ！
練乳！練乳！練乳だ！
れん・・・
はあぁ・・・
ハチミツです
これはね、お菓子のハチミツじゃないよ
あの、本当にね、純粋なハチミツっていうのは・・・
メチャクチャ栄養価が高い
砂糖とかのお遊び無しの、完全に１００％ハチミツなんで、
もうメチャクチャ健康にいいです
いやぁ、多分みんなが思ってるような
ちょっと美味しいハチミツとは味が違うので、
そこが果たしてかき氷にどう出るかがポイントでございます
なんか・・・
それらしくなりました
いだゃぁす！
普通にウマそう
あぁ・・・
濃いわ
次はこちら！
卵
卵でございます
ハッ？って思う方いるかもしれませんが、
まぁよ～く考えてみてください
うわっ！！　ヤバい！！　あぁ！！
卵かけご飯
味っ気のないご飯に
卵と醤油をかけるだけで
あれほどまでの風味が生まれ、
かき氷も然り、
たかが氷に見えましても、
卵と醤油をかけるだけで、
あっという間にご飯に・・・
あっとご・・・
あっという間に・・・か・・・
あっと・・・
あれ？かき氷じゃ無くなってね？
まぁいいでしょう！
細かいことは気にするんじゃない
大事なのは、
これが美味しいかどうかだ
うろろぉぇ・・・
はい、というわけでいろいろ試してみましたものの、
ハチミツとビールがギリかなぁ～
あとは本当になんか手のお終えなしてるもので
かき氷にはやっぱりシロップが一番だと思いました
「ポケモンＧＯ」外でやるとき、
気をつけろよ
じゃあな！
さて外行こ・・・